Hong Kong is holding what its
authorities term the first Patriots only
elections the new voting system has made
it near impossible for pro- democracy
candidates to get on the ballot across
the territory posters Billboards and
cheerful mascots urge residents to head
to the polls for the legislative vote we
are trying our best to get every WOTE
Hong Kong experienced its lowest turnout
ever back back in 2021 after Beijing
imposed its sweeping electoral
overhaul what's the point of voting the
political atmosphere is one-sided this
time the government has vetted the
candidates and drastically reduced the
number of seats decided directly by
voters so I'm afraid democracy is off
the agenda and whatever they're doing
now and whatever they are trying to
convince the public that the system that
we're given is better than the previous
ones
authorities began cracking down on
pro-democracy activists in response to
Major demonstrations in
2019 after they arrested her Agnes Chow
skipped bail and fled to Canada in
consideration of the political situation
in Hong Kong and my personal health my
hand mental health my physical
health and the high political risk of
being you know not being allowed to to
leave leave Hong Kong again I have
decided not to go back for those that
remain Hong Kong's executive Chief John
Lee announced plans for another National
Security Law next year now all eyes are
on the voter turn out to see how Keen
the territory's people are on the
changes IPM genford Al jazer